bello e tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo vi aspetti la che
cacchio comunque ragazzi se votati sul
rocket league per provare a fare una
custom e avevo promesso che abbiamo
provato a fare una custom in multiplayer
per la passione tra la facciamo più che
questo qua mi bamba questa roba mi
nascondo basta a check point a perché ti
sblocchi c'è poi man mano che vai avanti
quelli fighi qua è stata mondo ma sto
male ma bellissime dai ragazzi qua non
si venera anche della gente grazie a dio
perché sennò sarebbe un problema a c'è
anche tempo
per andare a baci e fattiva sbagliato
scusi incastrato dalle mutande di a nubi
e molto strano livello tecnico ma è
strano visto in quel catino di questo
l'inizio è questo tipo di fare il face
hateley byblos quindi si è però anche
tutta si cerca ton davanti avesse la
testa devo saltare un altro caso
pedana molto più avanti però dio dove
dove evitare gli store germinario perché
faccio casino comunque vieni bravo e c'è
il mio grand champion supersonica crowe
barclay james
91 ragazzi fatto è veramente figo e
vorrei aspettare the peccato perchè ho
paura di fare cose che poi magari
sbaglio ma
se ma come fai spiegami
giocare io no parla parla ma ragazzi
vigevano che sembra facile ma non è
facile ma non c'è modo per scappare
perché la io vedo che ci sono modi per
scappare vorrei dire ma era per dire io
vorrei andare
teoricamente non vedi che faccio un
simbolino sono dei fatti a numana mai
sono andato dall'altra parte si può
andare dall'altra parte scappando sì
perché da poi parlando e modi opere di
tutti i simboli esseno sblocchi il
finale nascosto presidente ma i check
point che sarà me ne frega na sega
desing dei simboli abbiamo cioè come
direttamente che sarebbe dovuto andare
io a ok quindi qual è la solo per
prenderli correre come cachi ai fatti
arrivare da quindi il praticamente prima
stava facendo europei in utile grazie
per avermelo detto no veramente non solo
ringraziarti davvero non facciamo cose
brutte di cui potremmo vendere siamo lì
sotto si sono solo io non ti spino
sottosopra sopra mai rincorso dai creato
il primo a l'uomo col cappello se
faceste il fascino per questo semplice
semplicissimo democratico ste cose poi
di schianto malissimo da qui invece ma
perché devo rimanere ma perché devo
rimanere incastrato mi spieghi perché
rimango incastrato cosa così di 4
secondi nostra ieri sera mi tocca il
culo è la quinta
sei mio ora come facciamo allora come
alla non mi ricordo se
faccio io allo scherzo scherzo però lo
faccio vedere io faccio io
vabbè ma non ci avrei possibile
bravissimo a no vabbè ma certo è sì
ovvio ma è ovvio l'é presa c'è point
esattamente a questo posso prendere
anche il centro che avete io tengo io
metto i suicidi ciniglia ragazzi è una
mappa impossibile mike è arrivato pero
su questa le
mappe che figo ma perché si poteva
trasportare anche tu ma bellissimo avere
questo è tosto ma figurati ecco visto in
usato solo per doppio salto in avanti in
una bella un bello giro avanti così
almeno mi scusi allora la sopra equa
destra sembra semplice ma non si fa
vedere
il caldo bravo marito seal dritto
divenuto ovvero il 7 lo tenga premuto
oddio ma lei è pazzo proprio girato lei
è bravo a dare consigli ma il mental
coach lei mister coach medita che
modelli e do del lei per i capelli nasa
turisti che pernottano sono c'è una
provata
[Risate]
io volevo spingere tecniche dall'altra
parte sono tranquillo vai vai tu non lo
ricordo benissimo dei parenti da qui dei
per un altro ayash questo altare oste
tosta che saltella da qua paro wayne a
risaltare a fare questo ethos tarello
questo non ho capito niente di quello
che hai fatto ma lo farò guarda guarda a
muro fai un beige
thousand years later assicuro che non si
può fare normalmente
no non lo so il meglio con le cure
faccio io
non lo farò attenzione però
ho fatto un giro pazzesco non c'entra
nulla bellissimo allora ascolta
dimentichiamo il jazz trash balagna qua
lasciamo perdere andiamo senza valeva
niente questa parte facciamo in gabbia
un'altra lasciamo che l'hai fatto subito
po di me lo ha fatto subito dopo di te
tu hai mille tentativi io in uno che ti
sei corrotto il file
dove 36 davanti al tempo davanti poi in
questo non ti stavo vedendo nostro
concentrato fare qua ora di arrivare al
cane per saltare sul cane per
piattaforme arrivare qua maps e il
prendi di check point c'era il fai tu
non ho capito niente di quello che hai
detto c'è il canada lo sciacallo davanti
no il cane cosa che faccio tanta ring
rope salta sul cane un groppo il cane in
gruppo il cane
poi dal cane era arrivato di sì poi dal
cane sono e piattaforma sinistra e come
ci arriva senza bus sul cane no che la
cosa si può arrivare ad archi e io
dovevamo farlo è uguale sì poi da lì
cioè a destra delle piattaforme vedi qui
a destra si aspetta
bella è che vengono fatti la cucina
mantovana dove vai sei pazzo
anche avevo capito non ha finora tutto
bene sta facendo legge ti voglio
guardare qui vedi
quello chi lo vuole in alto sottile
crosta quello sottile ma devo andare su
quello sottile che altera rally ma
potevo farlo anche dalla d'altura di
prima sono ma sì ma se c'è piuttosto
segue più facile pensano
allora ascolta milano casa cattivo devo
fare io mi sono semplicemente sono
tenuto quale un sonno come come con
sento dire ma poi anche presenza dal 37
di rincorsa eccolo proprio lui
era un attimo commentato di caricato
destra lato talami ad essa la mia destra
piano le pene a posto altri non c'è poi
ce la fa ci ho messo vent'anni ma
secondo se poi ci sono arrivati bene ma
dovetti dove dopo mandato prima era
giusto a 9 dice un altro la prima è sì
dobbiamo di verdi potevi quelle cioè poi
prima aspetta però no no no no no no non
è quindi prima 9 st un'altra zona ok ora
da qui la scusa di via
cerri no secondo me sì se salti meno e
si secondo me perché lo stridore voglio
provarci in ho provato io però voglio
proprio sapere proprio
[Musica]
non ce la fai però per l'attività è la
vera e scusa non vanno né brunone male
quello che c'è la nostra gemella sopra
la easy cacchio forza aspetto
aspettative non dovreste non bisogna
passare in a dove passi non idea ma
amazon si fa con questi doverlo sono un
po mai ce la facciano cose che hai fatto
per passare ai preso momento
così tanto tappa ripresa hai preso un
momento momento c è un momento
quasi
adesso
il laterale compreso il caso e l'ho
rifatto georges petit spetta
sempre un po di
ciao
amato microchip leggo mai kaki quale si
faccia a faccia che normalmente
aspetterò la provo salve arrivederci
tutto leggi tranne quando sono mi stanno
per ammazzare prova per come mi faccio
vedere io questo arrivo con brut
inalmente eccolo così male vero no no no
aspetto scoreggia no no non era turno
questa ero io avevo mangiato i fagioli e
per carità
il jump 37 tim cook si proprio lui e
trovarci e poi ragazzi totale ci
aspettano i costumi dovrai sbaglia vendo
d'acqua sui arrivederci io voglio fare
questo aspetto
tranquillo
scusami come cachi possibile di qualche
attacco dobbiamo andare sì di qui e poi
no ma ti
aiuta via io provo aspetto sui play
all'aiuto che ti prego ti prego aiuto
bisogna prima di grip
era molto più facile del previsto la
crisi ha creato e semplicità attraverso
di me questo è easy si no e poi
indirettamente c'è poi un allenatore che
questa mattina ma ciò che vorrei mai
fatti perché uno dovrebbe farsi la
palestra faccio una pazzia cioè è pazzo
ci è arrivato questo busto arrivo
anch'io regis
leggi
parlava para dove cacchio sfondo si è
nascosto
a parte il film
un buon pastore ragazzi questo giocano
dopo ma si levi per favore mi si levi
non l'ho fatto legittima per un
millesimo di secondo
c'è un millesimo di spazio andava bene
ma siamo fino a qua siamo fino a quasi
arriva verso la fine è giovata non passa
bacino di salve come si fa così quello
che hai fatto tu adesso faccio
aspettando che venga venga salve a
rivederci arrivederci alla prossima per
tendere stato divertente pensa farlo
senza check point e c'è chi lo fa
ovviamente bellissimo ero da qui andiamo
dritti così senza momento senza nulla
senza le virgole senza i punti
questa è bella semplice ma mi tenga il
gelato sto andando così per i fatti miei
ma io penso di dover andare qui sai che
forse no guarda guarda te c'è anche
salto esatto ha rivolto aspetta
e proprio lancio e poi diciamo questa
cosa salve attenzione che sembra una
cacata ma e sortino è infame in po la
presa del momento del momento del
momento venga al milan
faccia lei faccia lei agli aspetti che
io faccio pagare anzi guarda stupisco
io lo faccio lo faccio lo faccio
pazzesco miliardo di la voglia per stare
calmo rischiato veramente la vita va
bene allora questo infame lu dove riceve
farlo qua potete andare dove sei e poi
annunciato il giro del cielo del padre
sopra delle pedane sopra una questione
di venire
da vicino il sito è complicato girarsi
manovra e adesso che sto scivolando
eccolo sale 9 va mi scusi
parte fatto bene questo mi fa meglio è
sì non ce l'ho fatta ma educato e dentro
si ricadute
lo parla ci sono ci sono ci sono
e mo
la penso diritto non è vero faceva
abbastanza semplice quando ho parlato no
te l'ho detto la parte più difficile
quella parte l'ho fatto cioè poi
bravissimo pazzesco legis ragazzi l'ho
preso io l'ultimo mi sento
incredibilmente forte e da qua ad acqua
ci sta la piramide nolan chiuso lo
ricordo che l'hanno fatto pilato
e poi dove sono visti andare da qui
verso sinistra sempre a torino a bisogna
farsi l'intera piattaforma sul soffitto
per prendersi una cosa particolare sopra
cioè prendevano un segno di andare
semplicemente a destra dovesse dove
salto dopo il palo non m poi rincorsa
perché infatti famiglia fatta di meno
madonna madonna quanto momento vi sono
salvati domani la pazzesca le sei morto
morto ok perfetto è questa qua è
difficile perché siccome la devi fare
tutte in corsa no non per forza
perché colto tantissimo va in tv di
stato al corso il saltello infame
d'acqua poi dritto così e da qui santina
era molto più semplice del seguendo
l'esempio di semplice sono destra perché
ha senso se manca un po è invece il
tassista perché un
piano piano
io anno
ai lati bagaladi una volta in panne è
vero che hanno
scalo adesso dalla parte opposta
difficile unica che cacchio
fai devi fare due allievi taj no
internet e lo aspetto mi ricordo perché
l'acqua non devi non cadi poi da qui dei
per una cosa del genere poi salta è
porca miseria se va bene domani
la parte non niente sta che ci provo da
ci provo sommesso veramente tanto a
farlo
io non ci arrivo neanche col bus
ecco
chiesto dalle gite ragazzi 100 anni
presente a sud scudetto mai charo e alla
fine comunque da raggiungere non è
comunque scontato perché è lo stesso
difficile poi anche dall'altra parte
comunque qua ci sono delle cose per
andare a no non mi sa che qua è per poi
decidere intraprendere un'altra roba ok
a niente scherzi le moto comunque
all'ultimo non è così semplice ultimi
dati non sono così semplice no ma la
parte più difficile quella laghetto è
affatto facile
ok lega
totale gip proprio con buongiorno tale
gruppo dimafin in 25 minuti niente anche
se li prendi tutti questa è la parte
cinese greta che ha davvero c'è ed è un
altro parkour che ti porta fino alla
zona segreta ma impossibile per avere
con qualche scappati con
imposte tutto col bus ma va beh non
importa nella facciata travolta
rivederci è stato filo arrivederci spera
che gli sia piaciuta ragazzi ho usato
anche kyle lowry di niente visto che il
più sacro spray venisse raggiunto
presenterà che si vede un giuramento mi
piace come un'ingiustizia le si chiede
come si conciliano aveva subito bene
ragazzi
[Musica]